Corey kluber will be making his 14th
start of the Year facing his former team
four and three 4.02 72 strikeouts and
60. five innings pitch Corey kluber's
career with the Indians was amazing nine
years two Cy Young's three-time All-Star
won the AL wins leader ERA leader in
2017. he did it all
and he could not hold up curveball drops
lowen inside Zimmer swings and misses
two down a good pitch Lefty's love the
ball down and in but Corey kluber knows
how to make it down and then end up out
of the strike zone here's Jose Ramirez
his former teammate Jose Ramirez
celebrating his 29th birthday
and uh ground ball nice diving stop but
Ramirez beats it out gleber Torres did a
heck of a job to keep that from going
through but he just couldn't recover in
time and Jose Ramirez even though he
didn't get a lot on that he ends up with
a two out infield single it's a way to
start your birthday with a base hit and
here is from Neil Reyes
right back to kluber
underhands it to Rizzo and that's going
to do it well Zach pleaseack will be the
Indians uh starting pitcher police sack
is 10-5 on the year uh you know his
first major league win came against the
Yankees that was June 19 back in
Cleveland didn't have a chance to win
his last star because he was no hit for
the third time this year unreal two on
one out no score for Jean Carlos Stanton
it has 19 runs batted in in his last 21
games
right back up the middle might be two
there's one on to first they turn the
double play to end the inning and
another opportunity with a runner in
scoring position blows up
Ramirez he's the left fielder
punched into right field judge makes the
play fires the first got him double play
probably did not get back in time and a
bullet from Judge to ring up two Bradley
doubled off there a nice double play for
Corey kluber Joey Gallo leads off
Gallows hitting 200 right on the nose
35 home was 72 RBIs gallo hits one to
deep right field at his high that is far
it is God Joey Jackson
oh he really drilled it and the Yankees
take a one-nothing lead it's 36th of the
Year oh I tell you what all of a sudden
Joey Gallo starting to heat up
s but you also have one of the game's
Elite hitters walk into the plate so
here is Ramirez at that infield single
in the first inning rounded to First
backhanded by Rizzo and he fires the
kluber to get the final out
assorted off against kluber as we start
the fourth
swing and a miss curveball Rey is down
on strikes
a good hitter and a better pitch I mean
that is just the ball that just goes
sideways and that's been his pit Bobby
Bradley
swing and a Miss Bradley down on strikes
this was a well pitched at bat
by kluber in on Bradley's hands
the whole at bet Aaron judge leads off
against Zach pleaseette single to left
in the first and
that one has driven deep to Right Center
stroll back turning looking see ya into
the Yankee Bullpen judge goes the other
way and the Yankees have a two-nothing
lead that's just a quick 405 feet a ball
out over the plate he took this one for
his 35th home run of the year
great swing for very good first and
second nobody out in the top of the
order coming up the one two
up the middle kind of a knuckleball
there's one on to first they doubled up
the Speedy straw and a nice scoop by
Rizzo
moving to third Perez so here's Zimmer
with the runner at third and two up
shattered back slow ground ball to
Torres flips to Rizzo
and kuber gets out of it Reyes with 29
home runs and 77 rubies but he's over
two against kluba
that one is chop the Third
there's one on to First
it's a double play it's a huge play for
Corey kluber I'll tell you what a huge
inning a great pitch and no doubt about
it as you see Rizzo leaning out there
balls in the glove two outs and here is
Bradley here is the 1-0
swung on a high fly to left not deep
Gallo in mid left makes the catch
and indeed Corey Kluger pitches six
Innings here's our shella hunt first and
second no one out they have a
two-nothing lead and so it's important
to get the third run of the fourth round
the 2-2
that one is lined into center field it's
a base hit in front of straw Here Comes
Gallo he'll score the throw comes into
shortstop exit RBI single for Ursula and
it's three nothing Yanks shella does a
great job at just taking what the
pitcher gave him a ball up in the strike
zone out over the plate don't try to do
too much with it runners in scoring
position line it up the middle for the
second time tonight and a big run for
the Yankees and the Yankees still have
winners on first and second nobody out
for Gardner
driven deep
[Applause]
in home run for Gardner the tack on
inning works it is six nothing Yankees
big home run right here
three-run Homer blew this game wide open
you make it a lot easier on that Bullpen
now it's six nothing
brick Gardner quick to the ball
shooting him in the stands Giancarlo
tonight is over three
one two hit in the air to left field it
is high that is far it is gone a
stantonian home run the Yankees take a
seven nothing lead here is Joey gallo
High Drive center field straw back
turning looking see ya another home run
for Joey Gallo making it a habit it's
eight nothing Yanks back to back here's
Chang his first about took over for
Bradley in the field and now Lucas
lickey trying to close it out and he
does Chang strikes out and the Yankees
win eight nothing to start this
three-game set against the Indians Aaron
judge with a home run Joey Gallo with a
home run even Brett Gardner had a home
run
in fact Joey Gallo had two now let's not
forget Giancarlo Stanton so the Yanks
return to the Bronx and become the
bombers
as they have a rare blowout win
without nail biting and without that
much sweat they beat the Indians eight
nothing here on this Friday evening